JLo spent the weekend feeling nostalgic
over her twins and of course a New York
night out with fiance a rod
[Music]
two nights and two hot dates
JLo and a rod are still basking in the
engagement blow just nine days after a
rod popped the question
on Saturday the lovebirds dined at
Italian eatery Carbone and last night J
Lo's 15 carat bling was on full display
as they hit up the Polo bar but before
the couple's trip to the Big Apple JLo
was just a proud mama watching her 11
year old twins perform in their fifth
grade musical check out max singing his
heart out alongside a Rods ten-year-old
daughter Ella while Emmy held her own
during a solo number meanwhile Kim
Kardashian and Kanye West's daughter
Northwest stole the show at Kanye's
Sunday services Kanye has been hosting
weekly outdoor gatherings and this week
five year old North was feeling loved
music and just look how North lit hop
when her dad stepped up to the mummy now
to another talented kid who caught the
attention of Celine Dion during her
Vegas show over the weekend I'm going to
give you my microphone and you can turn
around and stay
[Music]
just look at Selena's face a
seven-year-old angelee belted out I
surrender
[Applause]
[Music]